[Musique]
ici il vient retrouver les traces d'une
mémoire qu'il a mis dix ans à rassembler
dans ses cartons des papiers des
affiches des objets aussi l'histoire de
la cgt et du mouvement ouvrier en
côte-d'or point d'orgue mai 68
à cette époque jean belin à 22 ans
employé au ptt
c'est son premier grand combat on était
jeunes on avait envie d'aller de l'avant
et cetera on avait envie de sortir d'une
situation qui était plus acceptable
surtout concernant la jeunesse plus
particulièrement on nie tout fait dans
cette société là à près de dix ans de
gaullisme
avec d'autres militants cgt jean a
amassé pas moins de 700 dossiers qu'il a
confié aux archives départementales
parmi ces documents ceux des ouvriers du
livre typographe et imprimeur un fonds
que cette archiviste est en train de
classer ses comptes rendus de réunions
date de 1930 c'est le fait de pouvoir en
quelque sorte touché le temps qui passe
c'est ça en fait est un peu le gardien
de la mémoire de ce syndicat du livre
alors là on a un diplôme en fait qui a
été octroyé à la chorale des
travailleurs du livre de dijon qui ont
reçu en 1891 le troisième prime de
lecture à vue ont fait un excès de la
lecture tout simple l'objectif c'était
déjà de fédérer les ouvriers au sein de
l'entreprise
mais c'était aussi finalement de faire
de cette union un véritable mode de vie
en quelque sorte un comme on dit l'union
fait la force c'est sain c'est ça le
butin du du syndicat du livre leurs
forces
les ouvriers du livre la montrerons près
d'un siècle plus tard avec ce journal
la bourgogne républicaine ont été remis
son histoire on a gardé sur une époque
là tu te retrouves sur la photo nous
sommes en 1983 les dépêches de dijon ont
été rachetés par le progrès l'impression
est transféré à lyon mais la côte-d'or
résiste c'était la saisie des journaux
qui était imprimé à lyon et pour pas
qu'ils soient distribués sur la côte
d'or et copains il récupérer les
journaux avant qu'ils arrivent à 10 ans
et puis les détruisez hondelatte était
balancé dans le canal c'était une
opération assez
en parallèle la bourgogne républicaine
est créé
c'est le journal de lutte ont fait à
leurs revendications essentielles
c'était le maintien du pluralisme et les
encours 70 cents quelques 120 ou 130
emplois sur des gens disparition d'un
titre ces disparitions ne se représente
pas si on veut
transmettre la mémoire du mouvement
ouvrier
il faut qu'on ait des traces au delà des
soins et des revendications qu'on change
et qu'on veut les acteurs puisque le
monde a changé mais un évidement quoi
c'est donner envie aux générations
d'aujourd'hui justement de démontrer que
les luttes assad et vous aussi toujours
du succès avec ce dépôt aux archives de
côte-d'or la mémoire ouvrière rejoint
les rouleaux du moyen-âge et la grande
histoire un symbole jusqu'à présent on
avait les sources disponibles dans les
archives des services de police les
services de la préfecture les services
de la justice
donc là il c'est intéressant pour les
historiens de pouvoir croiser finalement
les sources sont à dire officielle avec
des sources plus d'origine privée avec
des gens là qui était vraiment impliqué
directement dans le coeur des événements
les archives liées aux travailleurs du
livre seront ouvertes aux chercheurs dès
juillet le reste du dépôt de la cgt sera
mis à disposition progressivement
[Musique]